the motivation was the top 10 with
belief nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know that there's something greater
inside you as well you have Michael
Jordan level talent at something so get
ready to max out help others win and
believe in your worth with IDI my Lett
and my take on his top ten rules to
success volume 9 to give you the belief
confidence and motivation that you need
okay let's think it off with rule number
one max outt see I accepted a long time
ago I wasn't the smartest the
best-looking the fast enough with the
best background the most connections I'd
have any of those things what I could
control was my work ethic you've heard
me speak many times about out working
everybody but I think that just feels
good when we hear it but most people
don't take it seriously if you think
that I have a little bit of success in
my life I can tell you what I attribute
it to
yes self-confidence yes mindset
visualization goals all the things I
talk about all the time listening skills
influence energy transfer how to be
happier all of that stuff applies when
you get to winning for me it's come down
to maxing out and what maxing out means
is you do one more at least than you
think you're capable of so when you're
done whatever you're doing with it at
the gym or phone calls or meetings or in
sports one more shot one more throw one
more swing of the golf club or the
baseball bat the separator is for the
winners they do one more I'm addicted to
one more and so I want your mantra going
forward to be one more rule number to
help others win what are you doing to
intentionally create bliss in the lives
of the people that you care about
because this is the pathway to getting
more of it ourselves the more we begin
to give other people bliss the more
we're being to consciously make choices
that give bliss to other people in their
lives the more we begin to experience in
an abundance ourselves so what are you
doing to help other people win other
people contribute other people get
significance and recognition other
people have more peace
and ecstasy and joy and passion in their
lives because once you begin to create
it for other people when you're
intentional about it you'll have more of
it yourself these are the patterns that
I'd like to see kick in for you that
when they kick in you begin to run a
pattern in a program that leads you to
bliss lead you to a win lead you to
increase and also leads to it with
someone in your life that if you do have
a conflict with somebody that you run a
pattern that eventually leads maybe it's
understanding that maybe it's
confronting them maybe it's talking
about it it's not always when you're in
a disagreement that you lead to a win
that you must win this that you must
overcome the fact that they think this
of you what if you are consciously
choosing every time you got into a
disagreement with your spouse this will
eventually lead to more bliss at least
that was your outcome now the steps you
take it's probably going to be ugly in
the beginning you're probably going
after some understanding you may not
even agree on everything but if your
intention is that it leads to bliss
rather than you winning rather than you
controlling them rather than you making
it go away rather than you running a
pattern if when you're beginning to
succeed in business if your outcome is
more bliss more winning you'll run a
pattern that does more of that rule
number three chase your dreams you know
squirrels can't find 74% of the nuts
they hide what a fun factor what why is
that matter because you've been burying
your dreams all your damn life and guess
what you can't think you're waiting for
the right time
when winter comes you go find your
little acorns right you think you're
gonna find them let me tell you
something you keep burying those dreams
the longer you wait the harder they are
to find it's time you dig those things
out right now and find them and put them
right in front of you again and go chase
them you can have a great family and a
great business and a great financial
situation and feel great about yourself
and travel the world and do whatever the
heck it is you want but you need to dig
those dreams out right now rule number
four believe in your worth you know what
you allow is what's going to continue in
your life I put out a post about this
several weeks ago it's hard to accept
this but what's happening in our lives
we're allowing it to happen and to some
extent we almost believe we deserve it
because we produce in our life what we
really believe we're worth what we
really believe we deserve and it doesn't
it's hard to accept that because it
seems coincidental
you know that the wrong person or life
or there was a business setback or our
car broke down or you know our company
went out of business or whatever it
might be one of your clients just quit
and change their mind and it seems
coincidental but you really truly are
getting out of your life would you
believe your worth would you believe you
deserve and you're allowing it to happen
and I'm gonna challenge you today to
stop that stop allowing it and know that
you deserve better also if you want to
have more confidence check out my 250
for confidence series it's free the link
to join is in the description below the
minute you begin to get external in your
life worrying about what other people
think about you right you vote you've
lost all control you and it never fills
you up rule number five create raving
fans great businesses those either
they're business people great businesses
have a cult-like following have a
religious like following it's something
that all great movements have Apple has
it the great fitness companies that you
think of any company you know that's
really flourishing has kind of raving
fans and a level past that is almost
cult-like and religious like followers
they believe that deeply I mean by the
way I don't mean that in a sacrilegious
way like they believe in it more than
they believe in God you know exactly
what I mean when I say that deep raving
fans and those followings are led by
evangelist all great business people I
think all great dads all great moms
should be evangelical about their family
all great business leader should be
evangelist constantly touting the
greatness of your family the greatness
of where you're going the greatness of
your company rule number six be
different are you want to do the ugly by
the way do you know what the ugly is
right the ugly is doing all the stuff
the people who lose aren't willing to do
you got to make those phone calls you
got to see people you're gonna have to
put up with some rejection you got to
put yourself with an uncomfortable place
listen to me do it put yourself in an
uncomfortable place don't negotiate it
don't try to navigate it in your head
negotiation you will lose okay
unrealistic people rule the world quit
trying to be so dadgum realistic okay
remember this weird
normal poor can you remember that say
yes get a little goofy look at Cardone
he's a complete whack job just so you
know rule number seven take massive
action and then most people don't
understand you could obliterate most
problems with just massive action
I see people hem and haw and make
excuses all the time when challenges
arise and it would have just been solved
if you two decided you'd have been
totally certain and you don't litter ate
that problem with some massive action
rule number eight stop comparing I want
you to remember something comparison is
the pathway to unhappiness I'm telling
you that in every area of your life
where you find unhappiness you will find
comparison in fact the antithesis to
that is also true when there is no
comparison you cannot create unhappiness
in your life that's a pretty bold and
powerful statement but it's true we only
feel unhappy in our lives when we
compare something to maybe something in
our life that was a different time maybe
perhaps when we were wealthier or in a
different relationship or we were
healthier in some level comparing our
current conditions to previous ones that
comparison is what creates the
unhappiness that's actually not the
condition itself or perhaps you're in a
relationship where you compare it to a
previous relationship you had and how
they treat it or how you felt at that
time perhaps you compare this time in
your life just to a simply a different
time and that comparison will always
create unhappiness in your life if you
can remove yourself from comparing both
yourself to a previous time in your life
a previous condition a previous
situation or even comparing yourself to
other people in your life this is a
recipe and a formula for unhappiness
every single time in your life where
you're experiencing unhappiness you are
doing a comparison to something
it's the contradiction between your
current situation current relationship
current body current finances current
anything and something exterior either a
previous time in your life a previous
person your life or are you comparing
yours to someone else's it is an
insidious disease that so many people in
society suffer from today particularly
because of the advent of social media we
watched someone's video of what they're
doing on a Friday night and it's not
what they're doing that makes us unhappy
it's comparing
what they're doing to what we're doing
that makes us unhappy rule number nine
play offense the people in life listen
to me
the people in life that win play offense
not defense stop backing into everything
stand up bow your back a little bit
start to walk a little different start
to be that best version of you you can
do it in your quiet way you can do it
the way you do it but somehow they got
to look at you and go okay I won't
monkey with that one okay you read a
competitor you recruit them you can fail
you go get another recruit and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be clear on your
goals
ask yourself truthfully your big goals
and dreams are you really clear on what
they are because if you don't have that
we can't even get started but assuming
you've listened to all of my previous
content before you know how mandatory it
is to be clear and specific for what you
want right but then the next layer is
this can you get laser obsessively
focused almost to its exclusivity almost
but for an extended period of time can
you honestly say you've done that for an
extended period about a year two years
three years four years five years even a
decade towards something you want so
badly you want it like oxygens like you
want it like you want to eat you want it
like you want to live right well are you
extended ly laser focused on it or do
you get distracted easily now I have a
special bonus clip from Ed on how to get
focused that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go
watch number one what are three of your
most important clear goals number two
who do you need to stop comparing
yourself to number three how are you
going to take massive action this week
now if you like this video and you're
going to take immediate action after
watching it give me a hash tag believe
down in the comments below you got to
get focused I mean really let me prove
to you focus how easy focus is do me a
favor look around the room right now and
see if everything you could see that's
brown just look for brown brown brown
brown you gotta find something that's
brown brown brown brown brown brown
hurry up
see it see it see it you got some brown
stuff sandy brown it's hard to find
brown in here isn't it
make some crap up see some brown okay
close your eyes close your eyes do it
close them close them tell me everything
you see that's blue ah here's my guess
you saw more Brown than blue open your
eyes back up now look around the room
and find everything blue in the room do
you see more blue now because guess what
we get what we're looking for and we
filter out everything else in our life
you're gonna get what you're looking for
even if it doesn't even exist even if
it's not even there if you're looking
for negatives if you're looking for
setbacks if you're looking to be looked
over you will find it even though it's
not supposed to be there but if you
looking for victory for winning for
recruits for people to change your life
for magic moments you will find them if
you're looking for them I promise you
that's true in life
and if you want more add my lad check at
the top 50 rules video I did on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there will never lead you
to the person you were destined to be
ever in your life the thing that's going
to kill your dream is your addiction to
other people's approval